i might have a better angle
when he goes down you see the lights
doing the street that's that's where
he's trying to get to yeah trying to get
to the police that's it so there you go
right here boom this guy board hands up
kind of scared and uh kyle puts his gun
down rewind real quick couple of frames
here now go through this frame by frame
look shoot boom
guy puts his hands up okay like he's
kind of scared it's more of a reaction
so now kyle aims at him he's saying no
no no wait look kyle puts his gun aims
it back to the ground do you see that
aims it away from so the guy goes hey
hey hey you can see in the video kyle
puts his gun down yeah and then returns
it up to fire this is important here you
can go off that clip this is important
because anybody who is shot at the range
knows how much easier it is to go target
target target target then to practice
drawing and target it's something
everyone who owns a firearm responsible
firearms responsible firearm owners you
practice it every time
you should be anyway